[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 2 janvier bienvenue
dans cette première édition
d'information locale en 2018 tout de
suite les titres de ce set 8 journal une
nouvelle année qui commence avec
forcément son lot de bonnes résolutions
souvent difficile à tenir quelles
sont-elles pour 2018 elle nous sommes
allez vous poser la question faire du
sport par exemple pour éliminer les
loups repas de fête
reportage à suivre utiliser le travail
temporaire pour remettre les personnes
en difficulté sur le chemin de la
réussite professionnelle c'est le credo
d'idées intérim une nouvelle antenne a
ouvert à la verrière depuis octobre
invité de ce journal monia hunawihr
responsable de l'antenne et puis ce sera
notre fil rouge cette semaine retour sur
les principaux faits qui ont marqué
l'année 2010 est dans les yvelines ce
soir retour un an en arrière avec une
rétrospective de janvier à avril dernier
à des événements aux politiques mais pas
que
avant de débuter ce journal toute
l'équipe de tv 78 et moi même vous
souhaitons une très belle année 2010 8
pleine de réussite et de santé surtout
c'est le plus important
récurrent en cette période nous prenons
nos bonnes résolutions après avoir assis
à nous les tenons ou pas et en ce début
2010 8 quelles sont les résolutions
prises par les saint quentinois propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude aujourd'hui pas pris non comme
ça je suis sûr de les tenir pour la
santé peut-être faire du sport ouais
mais je me le dis tous les ans j'espère
que cette année ça va marcher
la santé ins et primeurs diana c'est
tout simplement
de prendre plus de temps de
de vivre ma vie de famille parce qu'on
essaie toujours travail travail travail
travail est d'essayer
voilà d'aider un petit peu plus les
autres parce que je pense que on est
dans un monde on est très égoïste de
continuer à ne rien faire puisque je
suis à la retraite la santé la famille
et puis et ça me suffit
mais je les prends tous les jours mes
résolutions alors je vais vous dire je
vois pas pourquoi il faut absolument que
ce soit le 1er janvier voyez oui moi je
veux rester jeune et beau absolument pas
je ne prends jamais de résolution sur la
manière meilleure manière pour ne pas
avoir ne pas les suivre donc pas de
résolution et tout va bien j'espère que
2018 sera aussi bien que 2017 et aussi
bien de 2019 et vous l'avez entendu dans
ce micro trottoir faire davantage de
sport est une résolution qui revient
chaque année après les nombreuses et
riches repas de fête il faut faire
fondre les quelques kilos pris pendant
la période
certains ne perdent pas de temps et se
met vite à l'exercice comme ce matin au
fitness park de montigny le bretonneux
reportage de me caler le mindoro ce
mardi de janvier à 9h dans celle de
fitness de montigny le bretonneux
habille déjà entrain de transpirer pour
tenir l'une de ses résolutions de
l'année 2018 faire du sport moi non moi
je voulais faire du programme le
tonifier me rappelle
là j'ai presque même pas une heure j'ai
dû me de coupe du monde de vélo il
fallait dix minutes de leurs amarres et
si j'ai le temps je perds 25 minutes
mais comme adil sont des dizaines de
sportifs dans cette salle amateurs ou
expérimentés à se lancer dans cette
course pour perdre les 2,3 kg stockées
en moyenne pendant les fêtes plutôt
détox peuvent époque ce parce que grosse
prise de preuve repose plus de poids le
point en soit on l'a on l'a depuis on
évacue on essaie d'évacuer un combat
continu avant soit on sort des repas rne
un peu joueur l'a pas trop envie de se
lever bon on vient quand même ça fait du
bien ça fait du bien au moral de voir
qu'on est nombreux à être dans la même
entre guillemets galère un phénomène qui
permet aux salles de sport d'enregistrer
deux à trois fois plus d'inscriptions en
janvier le deuxième mois le plus
rentable après septembre pour le monde
du fitness en fait en janvier souvent on
rencontre des gens qui ont qui n'ont
jamais accédé à une salle de sport ou
qui accéda qu'ils ne font plus de sport
depuis un certain nombre d'années et qui
prennent conscience justement à ce
moment précis de l'année qu'il faut
qu'ils se remettent à bouger un peu voir
le mois de janvier enregistre donc un
pic de fréquentation mais gare à la
démotivation
seulement un français sur deux inscrit
juste après les fêtes poursuit le sport
après le mois de mars
ils vont pour mission de maintenir
l'ordre dans une nuit marquée par les
incivilités les policiers yvelinois été
mobilisés pour le réveillon de la saint
sylvestre
bonsoir julien le cam vous êtes
secrétaire régional adjoint du syndicat
police alliance alliance police
nationale pardon à région est divine
on va dresser avec vous un bilan de
cette nuit du nouvel an dans les
yvelines nuit et journée d'hier 2
violences à l'encontre des policiers un
agent qui a été frappée en seine saint
denis deux policiers passaient
littéralement à tabac à champigny sur
marne dans le val de marne n'a des
images choquantes que nous avons décidé
de ne pas diffuser dans ce journal qui
montre une policière tabassé au sol par
une dizaine d'individus
vous avez pris par julien le cam cet
après midi à un rassemblement de soutien
devant le commissariat de champigny sur
marne pourquoi fallait-il se réunir tout
de suite très vite
également on avait des killers attendait
pour trois et que tous les jours sont
agressés en moyenne avec un chiffre qui
fait justement alors emmanuel macron a
promis depuis de punir les responsables
de ce lynchage qui a eu lieu à champigny
sur marne le syndicat alliance veut de
son côté voulait publier dans un
communiqué vu les le retour aux peines
plancher ces peines qui ont été abrogés
en 2014 par le gouvernement hollande
la réponse pénale n'est aujourd'hui pas
suffisante à vos yeux
pas du tout il ya une forme d'impunité à
la carte des territoires qu une réponse
pénale choix est fait qu'un délinquant
alors s'attaquer physiquement à copier
en prison et quelque chose il faut
absolument remettre en tête chez les
adultes tu espères de s'en prendre à un
petit physiquement à on peut voir que
les individus à l'arrière et à l'aider à
un sentiment d'impunité chichi ces
délinquants est très inquiétant qu'on
peut voir une forme de malaise besoin
comme vous l'avez résister 93 ans on a
également appris
mon pc ou même un chat donc plus de
moyens humains aussi j'imagine quand on
voit qu'il ya deux policiers qui se sont
retrouvés face à cette dizaine
d'individus on imagine que plus de
moyens humains sont sont aussi
nécessaires à bâle or ces temps le
dénonce depuis des années à d'ailleurs
d'entreprendre la même chose il faut
savoir que dans du sucre et cherré
département département seront également
touchés il faut savoir faire des
producteurs notamment
on compensera quête de cette fête des
effectifs est effectivement de savoir
que on manque énormément broyage de
véhicules sur le département qui va
arriver très rapidement pour terminer
dans les yvelines lui aussi très
compliqué 23 véhicules incendiés une
dizaine de feux de poubelles des
patrouilles aussi qui ont été prises à
partie ya eu notamment d'aider des tirs
de mortier qui ont été effectués sur sur
des des policiers à houilles
on a l'impression jeu américain c'est
que ce type d'incident est devenue
malheureusement habituels il n'a aucune
peur de s'en prendre à des produits
il y aura aucune conséquence pénale bien
lui en prit en prison ils sont mis en
prison que dans des cas extrêmes et il
faudrait généraliser cette pratique pour
que justement les individus et peur
comment vous expliquer comment une
dizaine de chaînes projectif et il
assure des sur des policiers
heureusement sans gravité en amont
déplore aucun blessé parmi les forces de
l'ordre sur le département et fait un
miracle
merci julien le cadavre est avec nous je
rappelle secrétaire régional adjoint du
syndicat alliance police nationale
région dit aziz line
2018 qui verra appliquer un plan daide
départementale pour les commune
yvelinoise de plus de 25000 habitants
cela est adoptée lors du dernier conseil
départemental en décembre et des fonds
qui doivent permettre de réaliser des
investissements et de lancer la
rénovation urbaine les détails avec ce
sujet de nicolas landry un plan des
départementales aux communes de plus de
25000 habitants
c'est l'objet d'une délibération votée
lors de la dernière séance de 2010 est
montant de l'envelope 40 millions
d'euros en investissements du
département des yvelines est allé sur
2018 et 2019 le département c'est le
partenaire puissant des communes qui
hélas sont en situation délicate parce
qu'elles sont saignés c'est comme une
année après année par les efforts
insensés
nous on essaye de concentrer toutes ses
dépenses et d'aider les communes a
concentré toutes ses dépenses sur des
équipements qui améliorent la qualité de
vie des habitants construction de
logements d'équipements publics ou
encore rénovation des routes des projets
d'infrastructure difficile à financer
seul pour de nombreuses communes une
problématique que connaît bien nicolas
dainville conseiller municipal
d'opposition à la verrière et nouveau
conseiller départemental
il remplace jean michel fourgous et
participait à sa première séance
alors c'est très complémentaire en effet
on a parlé de la verrière on a parlé du
renouvellement urbain
on a parlé effectivement d'un certain
nombre de communes donc le département
et les communes sont très
complémentaires sur beaucoup de sujets
donc effectivement tout est lié autre
enveloppe destinée aux communes un plan
des moeurs de 30 millions d'euros pour
la rénovation urbaine
objectif aider et soutenir les communes
pour leurs travaux de transformation
dans la tente des subventions de l'état
le programme nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine prévoit l'attribution
de 461 millions d'euros pour sept
projets yvelinois un sujet de nicolas
landry avec la voix de l'est a ré ge
politique toujours vous le savez c'est
une habitude tous les mardis dans 108
journal le portrait de la rédaction le
premier cette année 2018 est consacrée à
guy malandain le maire de trappes et à
80 cents à l'idylle le plus âgé de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son premier mandat politique remonte au
milieu des années 70 retour sur sa
carrière avec nicolas kirillovitch et à
un montage de xavier jallais 40 ans
qu'ils regardent lit et signe des
documents depuis ses débuts politiques
dans les années 70 et guy malandain a
tout connu
conseiller général en 1976 député des
yvelines en 1981 dans la foulée de la
victoire de françois mitterrand il
découvre saint-quentin-en-yvelines deux
ans plus tard et rejoint alors alain
d'année le maire ps de l'époque à
elancourt j'ai choisi elancourt parce
que je le rappelle la circonscription
couvrez couvre et rappelle encore vous
mord pas plaisir et c'est donc une très
très grande partie de ce qu'était la
ville nouvelle à cette époque ça ce
n'était pas comme ça et c'est à
elancourt que l'ingénieur de formation
exploitera ses connaissances et
capacités en matière d'urbanisme
c'est aussi dans cette ville qu'il
connaîtra des années compliquées en plus
d'un ministère qui lui échappe à la fin
des années 80 sur fond de tensions
socialistes ils encaissent une défaite
inattendue lors des élections
législatives de 1993 face à jean-michel
fourgous alors qu à bois d'arcy on est
aux anges des sympathisants sont en
liesse à l encours la déception envahi
le visage des proches sympathisants de
guy malandain
une déception que guy malandain su faire
sienne avec humour
itinéraire d'une défaite inattendue la
politique c'est comme ça ce sont des
victoires et des défaites il faut jamais
attendre en politique et le remerciement
de ce qu'on a fait pour ses concitoyens
dans l'immédiat je vais chercher du
travail
c'est tous aussi simple que ça du
guy malandain ans cherchera pas
longtemps en 1995 il quitte elancourt
pour rejoindre trappe
le début d'une longue histoire avec
cette ville particulière connue pour ses
artistes et ses problèmes de sécurité
une ville dont il est le maire depuis
2001 si on n'a pas
envie cet engagement d'aller serrer la
main au marché comment ça va il sait on
pas être élu et lui attrape amanda
particulier c'est un mandat piège au
sens de au sens que ça n'arrête pas
c'est les sollicitations sont
permanentes en tout genre mais mais mais
mais c'est un piège qui nous passionne
réélu en 2008 et 2014
guy malandain a changé profondément le
visage de la commune depuis 17 ans avec
une priorité mis sur la rénovation
urbaine reste un chantier majeur dans
les cartons depuis vingt ans celui de
l'enfouissement partiel de la nationale
10 les travaux devraient débuter en fin
d'année les élections à trappes sont
dominés par les sujets de l'urbanisme et
de la sécurité c'est la nationale 10 et
sur l'aménagement en attendant une
hypothétique déviation au large de
trappes parle à 12 20 ans dans un pays
pour faire un projet de 100 millions
d'euros qui traverse une ville de 30
mille habitants ça pose bien des
questions
on fait les fouilles archéologiques en
janvier ont commencé les dévoiements de
réseaux tous les tracés par terre et
c'est pour moi c'est ces partis ne
savait pas dire que c'est réglé
mais c'est parti les travaux pour la n10
parti et guy malandain lui ne part pas
au pays du président de 40 ans celui qui
fêtera ses 81 en juin prochain ne
s'interdit pas un nouveau mandat en 2020
avec moi sur ce plateau moyens aux nabis
bonsoir oms a fait sa directrice
d'agencé idée intérim une antenne a
ouvert depuis octobre sur la commune de
la verrière l'adresse c'est aussi ce ter
rue joseph rouleau alors vous utilisez
l'intérim et d'intérim utilise intérim
le travail temporaire comme un levier
d'insertion professionnelle pour
remettre sur les rails de la réussite
les personnes en difficulté quelle
différence finalement entre des intérêts
mais une agence d'intérim plus
traditionnel mais parce qu'en fait on
travaillé qu'un public dédié on
travaille sur des parcours
individualisés et personnels dans la
montée en compétence des publics est
également la levée des freins et on
s'appuie aussi sur un partenariat
multiple sur notre ancrage territorial
notre travail est impossible à faire
nos partenaires d'emploi les services
sociaux les politiques de la ville
également vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
de dd rénovation urbaine donc on y
participe aussi en aidant nos
entreprises à réaliser leurs heures
d'insertion
donc on utilise également cette
obligation là qu'ils ont justement de
répondre à cette clause d'insertion pour
mettre à disposition des publics qui
relève de l'insertion
et voilà c'est gagnant gagnant pour les
deux et la différence également c'est
que de 100% de nos publics sont
éligibles à l'insertion par l'activité
économique et font l'objet d'une
ouverture d'un agrément qui nous est
transmis par pôle emploi
je suis désolé j'ai pas la laisser
derrière leader intérim il ya une
démarche plus globale qui s'appelle
groupe dit des sept groupes idée tout à
fait pendant tout à fait donc idée
intérim existe que depuis 1991 donc on a
34 agences mais en effet donc le groupe
id est un ensemble d'entreprises
d'insertion
et pour compléter un petit peu leur
offre d'insertion et puis c'était aussi
pour un objectif de diversifier leurs
publics parce que une entreprise
d'insertion dont porte son projet et son
activité est fait de l'insertion au sein
de son entreprise avec ses freins de
production etc et pour justement
répondre à un large un plus large public
enfin voilà parce que on est généraliste
dans notre métier on est spécialisée
dans l'insertion mais on peut toucher à
tous les métiers possibles qui sont
ouverts l'insertion par l'activité
économique tant qu'il ya du public
éligible à ces secteurs là donc du coup
le groupe id a ouvert donc idée intérim
pour répondre à ça la présence depuis
combien d'années sur le territoire des
éléments fin 2010 et on a on travaille
sur l'ensemble du département donc du 78
et l'antenne a été ouverte que depuis
officiellement octobre 2017 c'est un
projet sur lequel je travaille depuis
2016 grâce ça qu'a pu aboutir donc grâce
à plusieurs partenaires et la ville de
la verrière donc qui nous accueille et
et la direccte bien sûr qu'ils nous qui
nous accompagnent dans ce projet là
parce qu'on peut pas du coude ouvrir de
nouvelles agences ou d'antennes sans
l'appui bien sûr des collectivités ni de
l'état qui nous finance on imagine
l'idée c'est d'être présent sur le
territoire sud yvelines
c'est pour justement apporter notre
offre d'insertion au plus proche de nos
publics et d'avoir un ancrage
territorial de proximité et d'être un
acteur économique du territoire
parce que bon sur le sud sur le nord
yvelines il paraît qu'on était un petit
peu trop loin et on n'était pas
privilégiée
par les partenaires emploi en termes de
prescriptions et d'orientation des
publics sur quel secteur vous proposez
vos missions et d'omissions aujourd'hui
l' agence de la verrière
parce que bon ça fait un moment qu'on
travaille sur le sud yvelines
on est sur la restauration collective un
petit peu de tertiaire et une majorité
du bâtiment donc comme je vous le dis je
le disais tout à l'heure sur la
rénovation urbaine entre autres et les
autres voilà sur du premier niveau de
qualification
dernière question on est début 2018
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter et
d'internet elles sont les finement les
projets pour 2018 alors la
concrétisation de l'antenne en agence
avec un eu un conventionnement état
propre à la verrière parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle dépend encore du 78
et de mener à bien donc le partage et le
portage administratives de tous les
dossiers sur sur l' agence de la
verrière
merci - yahoo en abyme avoir accueilli
directrice d'agents saïd et intérim une
antenne qui est au vert donc depuis
octobre sur la commune de la verrière
c'est tout sister je reprends l'adresse
six ter rue joseph rollo et pour plus
d'informations et notamment prendre
contact avec l'antenne vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran plus 4,7
pour cent de véhicules neufs
immatriculés en 2017 en france le marché
de l'automobile a été globalement bon
selon le comité des constructeurs
français d'automobiles ses résultats à
la hausse ont été boostées largement par
le groupe ps a implanté dans les
yvelines avait lisier poissy progression
également du côté de renault présent à
flins et au technocentre de guyancourt
toute cette semaine justement nous
revenons sur 2017 dans le 7-8 journal
sur les principaux faits qui se sont
déroulés dans les yvelines ce soir pour
ce premier volet nous vous proposons de
remonter le temps de janvier à avril
dernier au programme du voyage la
campagne pour les présidentielles des
exploits ou encore un anniversaire une
rétrospective de michael et demi d'euros
2010 est une année qui a débuté sur les
chapeaux de roue avec un record celui de
robert marchand le 4 janvier au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le sportif
réalise 22 points 5 km à 105 ans
j'ai prévu mais la fiche l'ailier lelia
minutes sinon était déjà été bloqué plus
justement les uns que j'attendais le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
théâtre d'un autre record mais cette
fois-ci handball féminin le 25 mars le
club d'issy paris s'impose contre brest
en championnat devant plus de 5000
spectateurs
du jamais vu franchement une grosse
salle bonne ambiance et je pense que si
on avait à coeur de bien faire mais
montrer quelques kilomètres du vélodrome
nationale le dimanche 5 mars bois d'arcy
a été la première étape du paris nice
les 22 équipes cyclistes ont dû
affronter le vent et la pluie pendant
les 148 km de course entre la vallée de
chevreuse et plaisir c'est finalement le
français arnaud démare qui remporte la
course dans les derniers mètres
ça a été une étape absolument magnifique
peut-être la plus belle étape de
paris-nice plus belle première étape de
paris nice depuis 20 ans 25 ans les
politiques ont également joué des coudes
au début de l'année 2010 est pour
remporter la victoire le 29 janvier à
paris benoît hamon alors député de la
11e circonscription des yvelines
remporte les primaires du parti
socialiste devant manuel valls 58%
nationalement 89% à trappes
je suis hyper content maintenant tout
reste à faire parce que c'est qu'une
primaire maintenant en route pour la
présidentielle
vers la victoire le
7 mai prochain quelques semaines plus
tard c'est finalement un ancien ministre
qui s'illustre le soir du premier tour
des élections présidentielles le 23
avril
emmanuel macron se qualifie pour le
second tour en devançant marine le pen
de trois points niveau national benoît
hamon termine 5ème avec 6 36% des voix
dans les yvelines le candidat dans
marche remporte les suffrages avec 29 %
juste devant françois fillon des
républicains j'étais venu juste un bout
de parcours sur un projet citoyen la
grande marche et de la voilà il a poussé
il nous a donné confiance en nous le
début d'année 2010 est a été également
marquée par une triste première dans les
yvelines à rhinocéros du parc zoologique
de thoiry a été tué par balle pendant la
nuit pour cecon par braconniers une des
défenses a été sectionné à la
tronçonneuse un fait inédit en europe
on part quand même du principe que les
animaux qui sont dans un parc zoologique
son protégé justement du braconnage
qu'on rencontre dans la cure donc là
c'est très très choquant dans les
yvelines plusieurs projets sont sortis
également de terre sur les quatre
premiers mois de l'année
saint-quentin-en-yvelines inauguré en
janvier le ski qu près de la gare un
incubateur pour l'entrepreneuriat dédié
à une trentaine de start up du
territoire du côté de plaisir les
travaux sur les fresques géantes dans le
quartier du vélib ou débuté en avril
au total huit dessins géants imaginé par
les habitants sont dessinés dans ce
quartier le 4000 habitants d'ici 2020 le
7 avril après cinq ans de travaux le
tout premier temple mormon de france
métropolitaine a été inaugurée au
chesnay en présence de l'ancien candidat
à la présidentielle américaine mitt
romney membres des mormons
coût total de l'opération 70 millions
d'euros entièrement financés par
l'église st les membres de l'église ici
en france et 2
ils ont l'occasion d'aller au temple à
madrid une fois en suisse mais
finalement nous avons ensemble aux
chaînés début 2017 le musée de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines a rouvert
ses portes après 18 mois de travaux 6000
objets sont exposés sur les 280 m² de la
structure il y avait besoin de doubler
cet espace parce que celui du musée
était devenu vraiment très restreint
dans l'ancien musée
ça fait plaisir de voir un an et demi de
travail de travaux aussi qu'ils
aboutissent dernières images de ses
quatre premiers mois dans les yvelines
un compte à rebours géant est installé
le 31 janvier à l'entrée de la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines
son objectif affiché les jours qui nous
séparent de la ryder cup la plus grande
compétition de golf au monde qui
opposera les européens aux amériques en
septembre 2018 au golf national à
guyancourt
l'horloge qui a annoncé 6 en quatre
jours ce jour la fiche moins de deux
cent soixante neuf jours aujourd'hui
avant de refermer ce premier journal de
2018 noël est passé mais les fêtes se
poursuivent au château de breteuil à
choisel toute cette semaine encore les
vacances y poursuivre décoration table
de noël dressé et visites guidées
séances de contes de perrault à 16h30 et
ateliers couture à parcours vivant vous
êtes par exemple proposé avec les
personnages de cire du musée grévin
interview au micro de michael et demi
d'euros l'objectif est de faire
découvrir à la fois l'histoire de france
d'une façon très ludique puisque notre
parcours de visite est agrémentée de
personnages de cire du musée grévin
donc ça rend vraiment l'histoire de
france attrayante elle se visite à
travers l'histoire d'une famille les
breteuil et puis le côté féerique
en plus du côté historique le côté
féerique c'est vraiment les contes de
perrault que vous pouvez découvrir en
vous promenant dans les dépendances du
château ya des conteuses tous les jours
pendant les vacances scolaires tous les
jours à 16h30
une conteuse raconte trois histoires de
charles perrault et là pendant les
vacances de noël
il y aura des contes de noël ou quand de
galles est mêlé aux pontes de perrault
les vacances de noël au château de
breteuil se poursuivre jusqu'à dimanche
entre est de 16 euros 40 pour les
adultes 13 euros 40 pour les enfants et
pour participer à l'atelier couture un
supplément de 3 3 euros
elle vous sera demandé et puis vigilance
de mise cette nuit et demain dans les
yvelines le département est placé comme
47 autres territoires en alerte orange
aux vents violents et des rafales de 100
à 110 km heure sont prévues à partir de
2 heures du matin et des coupures
d'électricité sont possibles il est
recommandé notamment de limiter ses
déplacements est limité à sa vitesse et
de d'éviter de se promener en forêt
l'alertent cours jusqu'à demain mercredi
13 heures c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal comme d'habitude vous pouvez
retrouver les reportages et le replay
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 78 bonne soirée
excellente semaine à tous
[Musique]